الان ما هو
ناتام تحديدا ولماذا سببت كل هذه المشكله
والمخاطر التي قد تؤثر على الرحلات
لكن في الحقيقه بدا العمل به منذ اكثر من
75 عاما
واخذت فكرته من نظام المماثل كان يقدم
النصائح لقباطنه السفن قبل الابحار في علي
البحار
تتناول اشعارات التحذير نوتام من مخاطر
القفز بالمظلات والعروض الجويه والطائرات
الشراعيه وتنبيهي للرحلات الجويه التي
تحمل رؤساء الدول على الارض التحذير من
المدارس والممرات المغلقه او حتى وجود
عوائق مؤقته مثل الرافعات في المطار او
حتى اضواء المدارس المعطله
ولا سنوات لكن في عام 2017 عندما حاولت
طائره الهبوط في سان فرانسيسكو لم تكون
معلومات السلامه واضحه منه طعم وكادت
الطائره ان تصطدم باربع طائرات اخرى كانت
متوقفه بالمطار وصل الامر بروبرت سمويلت
رئيس المجلس الوطني لسلامه النقل الى حد
وصف اشعارات نوتان بانها مجموعه من
القمامه التي لا يهتم بها احد ومن وقتها
خاضعا النظام لتحسين عديده
[موسيقى]